are we not so say what really happened
i fingered r2d2 and then aya
c-3po fisted me
look at these things look at that this
is horrible
and a lot of pain that's why I said
we're doing the interview right here
because I'm not moving for a week the
least sexy place where people often have
sex in the ass
wait no honestly I think it's in an
amtrak bathroom on a train because like
it smells in there and there's like
toilet paper and the conductor's like
knocking I heard that's what I heard if
I were to take a lover home to meet my
mother what's the worst thing it could
say to her
probably just introducing themselves as
my lover like what a creepy way of
phrasing that this is my lover the least
sexy sex scene in a movie probably the
sexy and Happiness where the guy like is
jerking off in the car that was not sexy
I wanted to embrace the genre of making
a rom-com because iíve always loved
rom-coms there so they just like leave
you feeling really good and hopeful no
I'm just kidding I knew Judd would make
a rom-com and I love money thank you
thank you thank you very welcome